antoine hier et aujourd'hui plusieurs
perquisitions et arrestations parmi les
proches alexeï navalni oui au total une
vingtaine de perquisitions en lien avec
les événements du 23 janvier ont été
menées pour violation des normes
sanitaires en effet les manifestations
de samedi dernier était interdite par
les autorités en raison des mesures de
lutte contre la pandémie de coronavirus
qui empêche tout rassemblement
en plus des perquisitions plusieurs
membres de l'entourage de l'opposant
russe ont été arrêtés comme son frère
oleg navalni ou encore ses
collaborateurs lubov sobol et leonid
volkov
ce dernier d'ailleurs accusé d'avoir
lancé des appels à manifester à
destination des mineurs
écoutez maintenant chez news corp et le
comité d' enquête de la fédération de
russie a engagé des poursuites pénales
contre volkov en vertu de l'article du
code pénal qui établit la responsabilité
pour incitation de mineurs via les
réseaux d'information et de
télécommunication à commettre des actes
illégaux
volkov savait pertinemment que les
autorités compétentes n'avait pas
autorisé l'organisation des
manifestations en raison de la situation
sanitaire et épidémiologique complexe
malgré cela ce 21 janvier il a publié
sur youtube des appels adressés aux
mineurs a participé le 23 janvier aux
manifestations non autorisée à moscou et
dans d'autres villes de russie dans des
conditions leur sécurité n'était pas
assurée général les autorités ne voient
pas d'un très bon oeil le rôle des
réseaux sociaux dans l'organisation
d'événements interdit en l'occurrence
les manifestations en question écoutez
le service fédéral de supervision des
communications des technologies de
l'information et des médias de masse a
fait un grand travail dans ce sens il a
exhorté divers réseaux sociaux à ne pas
devenir des plateformes pour ses appels
le parquet réagit également à cela c'est
compréhensible en tant qu'etat nous
aimerions qu'ils ne deviennent pas des
plateformes qui servent à annoncer de
telles actions et dégage autant la
procédure en appel d' alexeï navalni
concernant l'extension de sa détention à
une durée de 30 jours a été rejetée
l'opposant russe qui durant son audience
s'est plaint de n'avoir pu depuis son
arrestation le 17 janvier consulter ses
avocats en privé reste maintenant à
observer si les soutiens d'alex et la
vanille se mobiliseront une fois de plus
ce week end alors que le 2
février un tribunal de moscou va statuer
sur la violation de sa période
probatoire motifs de son arrestation à
son arrivée à moscou
un juge va donc décider si sa
condamnation avec sursis se transformera
ou non en peine de prison ferme
merci anthony claireaux pour toutes ces
précisions en direct de moscou